il est midi et les premiers verres de
bière sont versés pour la brasserie de
l'humain c'est sa première année au
salon de l'agriculture
implantée à hors scène dans l'indre elle
a ouvert un peu par hasard les patrons
étaient d'abord restaurateurs
ils prenaient la bière draga dans la
creuse en anglais
et là vous lui vendre sa brasserie il a
pris sa retraite depuis la forme mon
père pendant une semaine vite fait
histoire
le monde sait qu'ils ont arraché la
brasserie les a fait six ans qu'il vont
ça très souvent la bière c'est une
passion familiale qui se transforme en
activité économique alors les brasseurs
se forment et innovent
consommateurs est à la recherche
videmment de saveurs nouvelles et que la
bière permet de développer énormément de
produits dits fiers aujourd'hui on peut
à la voix avoir une grande diversité
dans les bières brunes mais aussi dans
les bières fruitées et puis je vous
invite aussi à découvrir finalement un
segment un peu spécifique qui sont les
biens sans alcool pour arriver à ces
saveurs les brasseurs se tourner vers
des matières premières locales pour sa
vingtaine de références la brasserie de
l'aurore installé à tauxigny en
indre-et-loire utilise par exemple
l'orge de pithiviers dans le loiret
le consommateur est vraiment locavore il
veut vraiment des produits de son
département de sa région de son canton
il a besoin de proximité de se
reconnaître dans dans les produits dans
ses valeurs et c'est pour ça qu'on a
aussi cette explosion ce que les gens
ont besoin de proximité en fait et de ce
qui circule cours
packaging soigné
récompenses mises en avant face à la
concurrence il faut se démarquer alors
leur îlienne propose désormais de suivre
toute la chaîne de production en flash
en un qr code la marque mise sur la
transparence
au début on a tellement été très peu de
brasserie en fait à être ferme et
brasseries et à pouvoir valoriser une
partie des céréales qui sont issu de
notre propre production et donc là ça
vient compléter une communication qui au
final va nous aider puisque nous petites
entreprises on n'avait pas forcément en
fait la volonté de pouvoir créer le
financement de pouvoir créer ce type
d'application les brasseries ont été
touchés par le col vide à cause de la
fermeture des restaurants elle espère
que la reprise sera au rendez vous